Hollywood's home to plenty of folks who
make a major Splash in the online world
that includes one man and his co-host
and their hit Channel on YouTube but
he's not a social media influencer or
movie star or at least didn't start out
that way he's just a guy watching planes
take off and land on the runways of LAX
Van Cleave has his story
oh boy Kevin Ray is a YouTube hit it's
already rolling down too far left more
than 100 000 people a week log on to
watch him on airline videos live
watching planes take off and land it's
so successful he playing spots full time
how is this a business the first
question that most people always ask me
are like are you making any money well
the track suits don't pay for themselves
no the track suits no it is definitely a
business what I've thought that I was
going to be doing this two years ago
absolutely not but back in 2021 he quit
his job as a TV news cameraman here's my
live trick again and launched his
airline videos YouTube channel which
features three weekly live shows
just as radio stations have a DJ Ray
calls himself a plane jockey he runs the
camera the live stream it's really quiet
out here and narrates I kind of merged
my knowledge of media with my love for
Aviation and took it to the next level
which is kind of like a TV show it was
rough at the beginning I mean the audio
was horrible you know it just it was not
good and um but people kept on showing
up showing up by the thousands to watch
hours of him tracking the comings and
goings of airplanes usually from a hotel
rooftop near LAX in Los Angeles here's
the thing in Los Angeles you never know
what you're going to see beautiful night
for a launch and I think people tune in
because they're like La is is you know
it's it's uh dramatic that is the
high-speed Pursuit dramatic can even
mean a car chase oh just another day
what are you most excited to see uh the
A380 the bigger the better if there's a
747 somewhere at the airports about to
take off from Land the camera is pointed
toward that there's something about the
747 everyone just loves it
a couple hours away in Redlands
California this retirement community
builds their day around Rey's show
airplanes it seems bring people together
see it's funny but it's just part of our
life and I love it that they have it
here for us Texas when Kevin took his
show on the road to Dallas Fort Worth
Steven nice to meet you fans were
waiting to spot him so what do you want
to be the pilot Brian Henry brought his
ten-year-old son Branson we found out
about these new YouTube plane spotting
channels it was just like
dude just make me laugh sometimes and
they're kind of cool
they're unique way of playing spotting
it makes me want to be a pilot using
nothing more than a laptop Rey produces
hours of live coverage that could pass
for a cable news channel Chris I think
you should come over even bringing on
the occasional special guest turning
reporter into interviewee for all the
web to see let us know if you need
anything else how do you fill five hours
of planes taken off we do have some
times where there's just nothing going
on and sit there and you start talking
about food you start talking about you
know what's going on in your life you
know the audience is still there they're
still watching
watching from around the world his
co-host and fellow plain jockey also a
school teacher Rudy Silva It's a mood
booster for a lot of us when Kevin was
like we're gonna do this did you think
it would take off like it has no I
thought it was going to be a one-time
thing and I didn't think I was still
going to be here to be honest with you
but here we are you all right yeah I'm
still alive I've always said you've got
to take risks in life get to where you
want to be and this is certainly was a
big risk of walking away from a good
paying job two years later it's taken
off
taking off allowing Rey to land the most
improbable dream job for CBS Saturday
morning I'm Chris Vancleave in Los
Angeles